so samantha stark director of framing
britney spears the first thing that i
wanted to ask you was
what did you set out to do with this you
know
we started uh we started doing this
researching for it i guess early last
year and the
uh the the purpose of it was to look
back at the media coverage of
brittany especially around like
2007-2008
through a 2020 at that time lens
you know post me too when you're uh
we're able to talk about mental health
more all these things and
when you look at the coverage uh it's so
shocking
really my jaw dropped with some of the
late night monologue moments or
interview
moments it it's just wild to look at it
through the lens of
how we live and speak about women now
right exactly so that's what we had set
out to do when we were originally
researching
um and i also thought you know there's
these photographs uh
these still frames that people always
think of when they think of britney
spears people don't know her so for
example a photo of her shaving her head
or a photo of her
hitting a paparazzo's car with an
umbrella those have
that those single frames have lasted for
so long
uh and i really wanted to know like what
was outside the frame
because there's been so much unfair
coverage of brittany and so many
assumptions about her
so that was originally what we were um
going for which is still definitely a
big part of the film is like what is
outside of this frame
and how framing britney spears yeah and
how much has this one frame affected her
life
uh people are still associating her with
that
those frames um and
as we were filming you know the the free
brittany movement was
was already going but they were
operating on this assumption that
brittany wanted
uh them to do it or that britney wanted
something to change in her
conservatorship because
as far as we know publicly for almost
the past 12 years she hasn't signaled
through the court that she wanted
anything to change that we know of
uh and so the fans were kind of
operating on this gut
instinct you know this doesn't seem
right something's wrong i think britney
doesn't want to be in the situation
she's in and while we were filming with
them
all these court documents started
dropping and all these
court filings where yes uh brittany does
indicate that she wants something to
change and brittany does indicate that
she wants her father
uh her father's role to change and so is
this like
vindication for the fans and then we
dove right in
having spoken to all the people that you
talk to
do you think that britney is signaling
for help in her social media what's your
thought on it that is the question i
mean um
since brittany has such a tight circle
around her
in part because of the conservatorship
or it's allowed to be that way because
of the conservatorship you know
journalists haven't really been able to
interview her freely
we as the new york times haven't
interviewed her because we
want to be able to do it freely with no
one
trying to adjust what she says or
anything and
it just feels like you can't ask
brittany uh and so
a lot of people look at her instagram
myself included and
just wonder what this is this appears to
be the only thing she
uh the only place where she's speaking
but
we don't know if she's controlling her
instagram also
so you you do say in the documentary you
list the people you reached out to
who all declined to be interviewed among
them uh jamie
spears her father her mother um people
from his legal team
what kind of responses of no did you get
uh we got a lot of people we just got
we got a lot of uh people who didn't
respond i think that's
you know i think it is kind of standard
that when you're in a legal
um proceeding you don't talk to the
media
um but i i think it's more than that
they haven't talked about it in so long
right we a lot of times we you know we
tried
everybody multiple ways um so
we would get i mean we did get a couple
people yell at us and hang up
um as you do but uh we also talked to a
lot of lawyers
um and had the response from them
and what about brittany you guys say
that you reached out to her and you
weren't even sure if she got your
requests what methods did you
try to use there it's really hard to
know
um since you know most of the time as
the new york times if i want to
interview somebody who's famous i would
call up their publicist and
send this request to this person and
sometimes
a lot of times the person will review it
and give it back to the publicist but
we're
unclear whether that happened and so you
know we talked we went through those
usual
uh places and then we also went through
people who
know her or know people who know her
that uh to get requests
in so we we asked in several different
ways um
but it is still unclear if she
definitely got them how do you feel
about the representation on both sides
like i
i don't know how you get the jamie
spears side when no one would give you
an interview but do you wish that
you had more from them and from the
family in there
well i mean to to to be clear we asked
them
several times over the court we gave
them every opportunity
to respond you know over the course of
many months
um and they declined
so we you know a lot of times we
uh pulled their responses from you know
at one point we have a washington post
article and we had to pull the response
from there or a page six article and
so we did we tried to put in and we
tried to we have a lot of media
commentary you'll like hear
this new news voices kind of throughout
the whole piece
um as like us as style because that's
what it's
the whole thing like hinges on news
coverage in a lot of ways but um
so we do get um you know
i went into the courtroom when we were
allowed to go into the courtroom towards
the end and
i heard all the arguments from jamie's
lawyers
and we tried to to represent the
arguments
there and so i don't think there's
actually um
to my knowledge that many arguments that
they presented that are
not represented in the piece it's really
interesting too to see because sometimes
i'll go on youtube and look up old
interviews
with her but to see it all compiled in
this documentary you really start to
remember
britney was doing interviews and
presenting a different personality years
ago
and what did you think as you were kind
of going through some of this old
footage and
seeing that brittany that we grew up
with
yeah i was um struck by how in control
she was uh how much power she seemed to
have
over uh what she was doing what she was
saying
and that also came from a lot of the
interviews that i did with these people
who were with her
toward the beginning of her career
everybody you know
individually separately all said you
know the biggest misconception of
brittany is that she was
a puppet that wasn't in control of what
she was doing
even as a teenager she knew exactly what
her music was going to sound like what
her
outfits were going to be how she wanted
to perform
i know at her first tour she performed
in overalls with bare feet because
that's what
she wanted to do um and so seeing how
much control she had been and and seeing
how she's like there's a
court-sanctioned conservatorship
in which she has uh is telling you know
can't control a lot of the key decisions
in her life um
is is surprising that contradiction to
watch
i didn't then nor do i now understand
what a conservatorship is
especially for somebody brittany's age
and somebody capable of so much that i
know firsthand she's capable of
it was fascinating to watch you talk to
her former assistant uh felicia
i'd never seen her do interviews
anywhere before how did you
get her to sit down with you and what
did you just kind of think of everything
she had to say
uh you know it took a long time to to
and to connect with fee and get her to
uh agree um i actually think you know
going through all the footage and all
the media coverage of her there's so
much
media coverage of brittany that's done
by men
and it was it was actually hard to find
women to interview
um at first so at jive records we were
you know the usual suspects are men that
are interviewed about the beginning of
her career so
we wanted to find a woman and we found
kim kaiman who was her marketing
uh executive who we actually through
talking to her realized like wow this
woman was so involved with
creating britney's image at the
beginning you know and so we came and
interviewed her we have a all-female
crew um on the on this on most almost
all of our shoots and
um you know our directors and producers
are all female and i think
kim was struck by that and so she
reached out to felicia
and like kind of vouched for us and
that's why felicia ended up talking to
us
i don't know if you asked her but did
she have any speculation on
you know just where britney is at
mentally and emotionally now um i mean
felicia maintained throughout that um
that you know what we see on instagram
is
you know britney loves to dance and she
loves to play around and
and she you know felicia worked for her
brittany within two months of the
conservatorship happening was guest
uh guest starring on tv on how i met
your mother and
like within uh the year was perform was
practicing for her next tour she had a
tour she had an album
and felicia came back to work on it and
she
was just really talking about how
how much how she felt like
britney could have made like a lot of
the decisions that were happening there
that was her opinion um you'll yeah
you'll see in the document did you feel
like felicia was
some kind of a representative to kind of
try and get brittany's voice out a
little bit since she's not involved in
the legality of it all since she could
speak
i do i think um felicia is one of the
people who
well from what i've heard from from many
people i've talked to
felicia is one of the people who
who has spent the most time with
brittany who knows brittany the the best
she feels i remember felicia said to me
there's just that all everybody's trying
to know what's in britney's heart
and there are just a handful of us who
know what's in her heart
and people keep keep searching for that
and i think
it was definitely a breakthrough in the
emotional story because
i it was very challenging to not have
people who talk about her and make
assumptions because there's it's so many
people just want to say
their whole think piece on brittany and
and like
they don't know but felicia actually
knows her and
you know she says in the piece i wanted
to um i wanted to remind people of why
they fell in love with brittany in the
first place
is there a reason that she doesn't
speak out more or didn't do interviews
before
what do you think that is if anything i
think um
anyone close to brittany uh really
feels the power of getting burned by the
media
there's a moment uh where you know we're
talking about the media coverage of this
the paparazzi
and you asked the paparazzo who was
there
for that umbrella moment his car was
smashed and you asked him about
his feelings on the whole thing and he
says well britney
never asked us to leave her alone danny
does say in the documentary like it was
hard to understand
what she was going through when we were
in the moment one of the reasons we
wanted danny to tell that story
is that because he was videotaping so we
could see the video so
when you look at it it's you know it's
this epic moment in a
in a still frame photograph but it
lasted like two seconds when you watch
it on video
um and he tells the story that he had
actually been following her around
um before that for a really long time as
she was attempting to see her kids
and and wasn't able to and so like if
you're a mother and you're not able to
see your kids when you want to and
somebody
is coming up to you asking you questions
about it
the full story behind the picture yeah
what do you think is the future
of her conservatorship having been to
the hearings and and done all the
research that you've done where do you
see it going
um yeah i mean i think a lot of people
see a lot of symbolism
and this idea that her father is
controlling her
like uh symbolic of the patriarchy but
actually literally
um but uh you know
these court uh hearings keep it's
it's lasted a long time and something
that we bring up in the film
you know is by looking at brittany's
story there's a lot of questions we have
about the conservatorship system and if
there's like
areas where it could possibly there
could be conflicts of interest
so for example britney is paying for
her own lawyers and she's also paying
for her father's lawyers
and she pays for the her conservators
as well and so um
some people could see opportunity for
there to be a conflict of interest
because as long as the conservatorship
keeps going all those people keep
getting paid
um and also paying for lawyers to argue
against each other is so
unique so
my prediction is it's going to last a
long time and
for you what barriers did you encounter
while trying to make this movie
if any were there people trying to stop
you from different sides of the legal
battle
yeah yeah
for sure so many people around brittany
have ndas
and they you know would have to pay a
lot of money if they said
anything um people were scared um
jamie's
team has sued some fans before um and
you know there's a legal threat that way
i mean we are the new york times so we
weren't worried like we wanted to go
after
everybody but we've gotten some calls
from some lawyers
[Music]
sure